[Applause]
you are now the longest running game
show host television history
wow what does that mean 40 years almost
is like unfathomable congratulations i'm
very excited and happy to be part of
wheel of fortune and i want to ask you
what is the magic of pat because he does
feel like a family friend including me i
mean we've been together 38 years and
he's like my brother
he's funny well that's disappointing
got it good
pat
how much longer would you do this we're
certainly closer to the end in the
beginning i'd like to leave before
people tune in and look at me and say
what happened to him i wouldn't bet on
it seeing us in 10 years i would say is
that fair probably yes
so for now pat and vanna are staying
busy jason alexander thank you
season two of their popular celebrity
wheel of fortune premieres sunday night
on abc jason will be joined by dancing
pro cheryl burke and contestant wwe star
the miz if there's a star you could pick
from
right now four wheel who would it be oh
my i would pick meryl streep because i
just want to have meryl streep stand
there and say come on big money
that's my dream merrill if you're
watching we can't give you an oscar but
please
[Music]
you